hello and welcome to this video playing
mmv bar I'm Germany so what do you have
in store not knight c6 okay Bishop to
sex okay that's very rare because
divorce kind of normal here so what's
the deal with this yeah I can just take
for a simple solution I wonder maybe
Bishop g5 and then take but you know I'm
taking I'm spending too much time here
on on on a situation where white will be
better no matter what I play and I
should just play it and quicker okay so
um certain you more than one thing here
it just Quincy to I have this additional
porn in the center which is nice so look
at you one stop doing all that much I
can also feel care to maybe do that not
sure
nice moves I want to play and he gives
it to me with big tempe efore f-4s part
of white strategy m okay so we'll just
just have to be aware of of technical
technical stuff anyway if I've is kind
of normal unfortunately I cannot play
around this Bishop that well i think i
have to really okay maybe Bishop e3
actually Bishop a 394 I it could be even
better than just play 94 straight away
okay yeah I'm still going with this you
always see going Bishop f5 or something
like that
okay so he went with this so i have to
take and then green move to unpin may be
here and then 96 it takes quite a bit 96
f 5 v eight and so on
don't see a good move from 96 should win
material
yeah I really don't see move yeah I
expected that it's probably relatively
relatively best choice knight on d5
still alone provide some some
counterplay hopes okay night here
somewhere centralized have to make sure
that I'm not stumbling into some
tactical tritium we know the nights
nights are dangerous rook t4 may be
Queen g2 now would blunder stuff
okay a Quincy phone some breakthrough 86
would be good so before him a4 b5 is
this would be nice to get but the moment
I don't see how actually
so is coming with H for you
my position is somewhat loose it's just
what it is it's not totally easy
Queen g4 I go f5 smile Jim f5 now maybe
let's do it I need to get something
going here if he takes rook edge for him
pawn takes rook edge four wins the Queen
so he has to take with the Queen and
then I'll take package for and wind upon
its not yet winning at least in terms of
blitz chess and all kinds of stupid
stuff can happen that's funny
that's a self-penned oh I'm sure that's
a technically good move to be honest
King g6
check
so it can take over six cents a winning
King and porn ending would it's no need
to black resigns ok so in 56 is a bit of
a strange move d for should be ok i just
spent too much time like 30 seconds for
that move I mean why it is going to be
better here anyway so I should just play
it quicker what is better because of the
extra Center porn and what he did is
actually helped me a lot by giving me
all those books that I want to try
anyway I think widest English good shape
Ian this one yeah no one less it's good
for wide this is what the engine is
giving yeah obviously quite nice with
something like this I a nite CH cocaine
white is still better with this there's
two things attacked a plate this and now
it should be added wins the exchange he
could have played this and sacrifice on
d6 might even lose exchange in you might
awards I mean he has no good square this
is just a enormous fork and check and
here it's a little bit a little bit
annoying there with the night I could
have taken a seven sure
done that not so much for the porn but
if I can take place out as well then his
whole position falls apart and it
probably was the right move yeah I was
shuffling a little bit trying around
this I think is a good solution if he
takes with a pawn you blend us the Queen
and after the commune traders ending
should be should be winning now King
just six is a little bit tougher here I
think I gauge 388 this is what the
engine is giving not sure before what's
the thing he wants to go chat forum
maybe why should win but it's done in
blitz yeah okay h3 was basically
trapping the noise check okay if you see
one witness enough ya hear the capture
should win of course but there's no real
need II cannot move for anything here so
um there was no urgency to do this okay
give me the night okay well guys thanks
for watching